you have insulted everybody every cast
member up here you insult everyone okay
it's not my turn it's not my turn hey
you had your turn yesterday I'll be
quiet
zinny has had it with big Ed the way she
told him to be quiet gave me flashbacks
to my childhood I'll be quiet Jenny goes
off on Big Ed for his behavior toward
the cast you still told everybody
seriously find me a river he is man he's
the worst thing I've ever met in my life
she called him a thing
and she isn't the only one fed up yeah
I'm just gonna tell you you're lucky
that's going on in the studio because if
not somebody would probably beat your
ass talking to people's women the way
you do I wonder if that somebody is Jovi
plus Jenny Angela Kim and Liz become the
girlfriend group you never expected but
there's this move that he does we call
it the power bike God damn that's all
I'm gonna say I think I'm calling Jesus
when this happens it's bad sorry oh God
isn't it well I'm kind of pissed I ain't
called Jesus yet I called you both they
were a fun time let's get into it
hey money day fans fam it's melicia I
hope you're doing well we have made it
to the fourth and final part of the
tell-all to be honest I thought this
episode was going to be a little blah
because they stretched the tell-all out
so much but to my surprise I was
entertained in large part thanks to
Jenny Jenny went from being The Quiet
One in the corner to snapping on Ed for
everybody here's how it went down Jovi
is a provider whether you like it or not
you should have never married him and
now imagine I'm looking for a b Plan B
and started to give his two cents on
Jovi and yara's relationship going hard
for no reason I'm looking for a b Plan B
yes you are such a user like you are now
we're the last person you don't respect
Jovi number one
instead of supporting him in a bowl to
Europe
I don't like you but in this situation
all right can we shut him up already
nobody wants to hear it nobody wants to
hear this nobody wants to hear the
you're you're a crybaby is this the
kindergarten classroom that's what it
sounds like come on Ed every attack or
everything you think is an attack
doesn't need a reaction especially not
an immature one this was the boiling
point for Jenny you're a crybaby don't
you be quiet shoo fly don't bother me
don't you be quiet if God had enough of
this guy insults to everybody why would
you say Jovi's crying baby you have
insulted everybody every cast member up
here you insult everyone okay it's not
my turn it's not my turn hey you had
your turn yesterday oh be quiet you had
your turn yesterday everybody stop it
you had your turn yesterday
oh he made Jenny get out her chair you
had your turn yesterday kiss my ass dude
so shut up whoa you shut up
am I the only one who was thinking
submit what you gonna do Big Ed is
coming for your lady what you gonna do
clearly Jenny can hold her own but I
would have loved to see some misreaction
if he was there in person at the
sell-off
over Zoom he didn't do much you're so
ritual everybody seriously find me a
river
says whatever it's the worst thing I've
ever met my life as Jenny calms down a
bit the conversation turns back to Jovi
and yara's issues mainly that yara's
friends haven't seemed to be too
supportive of her being with Jovi in the
past when it comes down to it I'm not in
the relationship with Jovi and Yara I'm
yara's friend so I'm in interest of her
best interest so they get a divorce
because you support her why why am I
getting divorced what you talking about
yeah you guys are jumping to conclusions
you're being a wuss you can't even
manage your family
you're not man enough to manage your
family Santa's face is mine right now
it's like what
he's stuck in that mentality of you
attack me I'm gonna say the worst
possible thing and attack you back it's
a protective mechanism that is no longer
serving him I'm sure it stops serving
him a long time ago we are adults now Ed
you don't have to protect yourself on
the playground anymore you want to buy a
place in Prague didn't I hear that I buy
your name in your daughter's name not in
his name you and your daughter's name
you never mentioned him until you got
busted
bastard Elizabeth you yesterday
so you because you're such a shame me
you're trying to say
shut up such a shame he tried to show
this year your husband
shut the [__] up nobody wants to hear
you you're a [__] no I'm serious Joby
couldn't even take Ed seriously yeah no
I'm serious [__] I mean that
you're letting her ruin your life what
is wrong with y'all y'all need to grow
up oh my gosh
and how old are you wait do y'all see
Ed's reaction his eyes got super big
that's not the first time I've seen him
do that either it happens whenever he
gets called out or caught for doing
something wrong that's how old are you
me and my empathetic behind wants Ed to
go get some help she's obviously
struggled with some self-esteem hurdles
which is understandable I'm sure since
he was a kid he's had to defend himself
against people who would talk about him
but this Persona he's created to protect
himself is now destroying the positive
relationships he could have as an adult
I'm sure it won't be an easy process but
it's time to mature big head gotta grow
up at this point just drop the big and
be it as a matter of fact you're Edward
you were gonna shut the door and leave
me out
what is it
raps and Jenny Kim and Gara get into one
car headed to the after party
and y'all Jenny has this side to her
that is just now coming out on the show
and I love it Jenny is cool
you always shove some shades yeah when
he's told me to shut them up I looked at
Yara I did that first thing I looked at
y'all like it's stuck in me
when you got mad I was like in my head
I'm like go Jenny
you called it man yeah
who does he think he is how dare he say
anything to anybody look at him is he
perfect
Jenny and that hell no had me laughing
out loud multiple times I kept rewinding
this moment
even look at him is he perfect
anybody look at him is he perfect what's
up Jenny come hang let's go get a drink
girl I am here for this meanwhile while
the girls are cute King in one car Joby
is in another with Ed and just like
Jenny I appreciate seeing this side of
Joby as well yesterday sucks and um
today I Just Came Out Swinging anybody
that took me down I was going to take
him down yeah I'm just going to tell you
you're lucky that's going on in the
studio because if not somebody would
probably beat your ass talking to
people's women the way you do wow
chivalry is not dead go Yara Jovi isn't
perfect but the way he kept his tone
calm but direct is attractive if a woman
goes after you do not handle the
situation that way you can fight back
but you don't need to get aggressive and
you don't need to scream at a woman
including my wife well what about you
including what about you I didn't scream
at any woman in there big ad goes on to
admit his behavior during the tell-all
was out of line especially toward Liz
I'm ashamed of the way I behaved
yesterday there's no excuse for that
because you took it over the top to a
point where we had no choice but to go
after you instead of her absolutely and
you did the right thing I was
mad Ed also has this habit of acting out
and then apologizing right after
which Joby and Yara call out once they
get to the hotel she is such a clone
that's his thing he's a clone clown yes
that was cute he was saying one stupid
thing and he apologized you're so dumb
don't say that stuff before you die
after don't apologize I can't take
anyone like that serious because he's
like oh Jovi you're you're a [__]
you're a [__] whatever and they're like
oh I'm so sorry like how old are you
like are you seven years old or what
like come on well when it comes to ex
fiance Liz she says after all his lies
and deception including being on a
dating app and talking to his ex Rose
she's done with him she claims she's
gonna focus on herself so hopefully she
sticks with that he's a liar he'll never
change his behavior
period
[Applause]
Liz also has Jenny to give her that
extra boost after Calling it Quits with
Ed you deserve so much better what are
you doing with that guy oh we all need
friends like that after a breakup boy I
tell you okay real quick I gotta tell
you so my new license plate that I just
put on my car don't tell me it says big
head it says Big Ed's girl and now I
gotta go I'm gonna punch you in the face
right now Liz Kim Jenny and Angela also
end up having this girl chat moment that
I didn't know I needed to see from them
feels a little uncomfortable at some
points but overall a good time I'm gonna
say this because we're all having a fun
time but she's so full because I'm
telling you I see her heart and she's so
much like me she's too forgiving she's
gonna talk no one's gonna tell Angela
she has a nip slip but somehow another
guarantee you you're gonna see the
romance spark again no it won't mark my
word I mean I might go get some but
Michael get something
you're so right Angela goes from telling
Kim she's going to get back with Usman
to asking how was their intimacy
together so is it good yes yes and let
me tell you it's it's it's
um different than what I've been used to
I will see my face is red right but it's
good but it's been an overtime thing you
know what I'm saying anything
um yes but there's this move that he
does we call it the power bike goddamn
that's what I'm gonna say I think I'm
calling Jesus when this happens it's
that sorry oh god well I'm kind of
pissed I ain't called Jesus yeah I
called you though I'm just saying the
ladies then turned to Jenny and ask how
submit is in bed
cement is perfect for me okay Jenny said
that's all you need to know there was
always that one friend who was like I'm
not telling y'all my business and my
thought is girl relax we don't care that
much
I'm just kidding I'm not mad at it to be
real some friends you don't need to tell
them about your intimate moments with
your partner
and you know why curiosity killed so
what is what's the favorite thing he
does before y'all have sex is he kiss
you caress you
massage give us really nice massages you
know my neck always hurts on the side I
bet it does shut up I bet he's decided
he's such a silly girl you're a silly
girl you love me though Angela goes on
to detail her sex life with Michael well
I'll tell you what Michael does
Cindy Jenny is my favorite cast member
on this selloff
but when he tries but he's very good
because I teach in him right don't worry
I've had to teach my last partner for
the last two years and he still can't
kiss yeah I want to tell you it all he
thought about was you take your clothes
off and you have sex to First you go in
I'm older number one uh yeah I got
juices but you gotta flow them like oh
my God Angela as they treat we're older
women like she probably can just one can
go for her because
ours is older and you got to play with
us yeah it's the cruise some of y'all
okay out there
just checking the girl chat ends with
the ladies toasting to the single life
and Jenny joining in for moral support
I'm gonna say this
cheers to a very healthy relationship
cheers to two single
woman possible three possibly three
and if you're single we are all going
out to me being single to me being
singles
shut up you're gonna go back to Michael
too I can hear your voice now [__] I
can hear your voice now Michael
Michael
look at Angela talking about I never
said I wasn't
she's not tired yet
wow endurance all right next week is the
premiere of season four of 90 Day Fiance
the other way and we have some new
couples to get to know
Osama he makes me feel young again are
you okay my love I'm really homesick
oh cross fingers let's hope they're
actually interesting that would make my
job a lot easier
all right 90 day fans fam this season of
Happily Ever After was fun as always I
appreciate you so much so so much make
sure you stick with ET because we are
covering it off I will see you next time
foreign